hey what's up so I've had this
relatively dumb research idea and people
have been asking me for more coding
videos and so on so I thought why not do
a video where I take a research idea and
implement it from scratch just to show
how one would go or how I would go about
implementing something like this
now this was simply meant as sort of a
demonstration but then at the end it
actually worked and so yeah that was
unexpected and my initial reaction was
just to be like oh crap
just to hold everything you know stop
video making he developed the idea write
a paper about it okay and I was about
doing that when I realized that you know
I'm always the one complaining that
research is not transparent enough and
people aren't open enough and so on so I
sort of thought I might do a different
thing right here in that I will actually
share the process of this non finished
research project so currently I am in
the middle of this I have no idea
whether it's going to work out or not
and that's it and I think we can do open
source software development you know
completely in the open
whereas with research we're all like
super scared that people are gonna scoop
us and we people just keep it keep their
work hidden until they're done and then
boom they put it on archive and all I
want to go to a world where we
collaborate much more in research and
it's much more like open-source software
development so here is my way here
here's my process of implementing this
idea and it's fairly long so if you just
want to get to the results you can just
skip at the end I'll put timestamps in
there's this new YouTube chapter video
so that'll be very helpful
I guess yeah and with that being said I
hope you enjoy this let me know what you
think of videos like this and I'll see
you next time hey what's going on today
we're going to take a research idea and
implement it as fast as we can so this
is not really to show you the best
research idea because it's not and it's
probably been done before so I have no
high hopes here but this is just to show
that if you had like some research idea
and you've actually done the literature
research and figured no one has done
that yet which I haven't because
probably someone has done that how you
could take this and like get start it up
initially pretty quickly and this is
just the process that I would go through
and I'm going to go through with you
today and we're going to try to get this
up and running as quickly as possible so
I had this idea that looking at Sinclair
v2 there's a lot of things to be done
still in the space of let's say self
teaching self distillation and so on you
know there's mean teacher and then
there's um whatnot and this is all
usually done in the semi-supervised very
few label regime and so on but we know
that these self supervised techniques
can help you in supervised learning and
then in Sinclair v2 you do
semi-supervised in that you do self
supervise and then fully supervised and
then distillation like self distillation
there's there's all these kinds of
interleaving stuff and I thought okay
what if I just take a pre train network
that performs really well on something
and I self distill it into a bunch of
student models like a number like 10 or
so and then I like that's my ensemble
model will that perform better than the
original model like this is a terrible
idea and it's probably not going to work
like there's 99% chance it's not going
to work
but let's try to test this today so I
got my drink I got my carbs since it's
weekend and we're going to give this a
shot all right so first thing we need
some sort of base to go from in research
it's good to build your own stuff but a
lot of times if you want to be as fast
as possible you want to go as quickly as
you can so here
I found this repo thankfully with an MIT
license so shout out to who who even fun
I guess for training for putting up a
repo training these see for 10 models or
training these PI torch vision models on
C for 10 C for 10 is a small enough data
set so that we can kind of work with it
and these models are already pre trained
so I've cloned this repo and we're going
to adjust that so there is a first of
all there is a download as you can see
here which in this report says it
downloads these I have not done this
before I have no clue how this is gonna
work out in this download script here
downloads the weights from box and I
hope you can see this and then I guess
you can load the the pre-trained weights
with pre-trained equals true and yeah
we'll get into all that later so the
first thing we got to do is get this to
run let's say so let's look at this
downloads thing first
so the download thing is going to have a
URL it's going to use requests to get
that URL and then save this into this
state big thing now what I usually want
to do is I don't I want my folder of
code to only have code and not to be
intermixed with data and code because
this is the thing that I'm gonna ship
around to various servers and so on so
I'd rather have the code in one folder
and then the date and like a central
folder so I'm not really fine with this
sort of downloading the this right here
into into the folder that we have so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
change that such that it downloads it
into a central folder so first we
already have OS so what we're going to
do is we're going to get some like data
path going which is going to be our home
folder OS path and I guess I also
already have AC for 10 folder right here
we'll use this and then haha
so half dot join will join that and
that's going to download it's not really
data is it it's more like models okay
let's do this
cool so data path is this is the models
that is going to download all right and
then it unzips the file again so here it
unzips the file to the current working
directory I don't want this so I'm going
to change that again to the models path
all right nope directory to path to zip
file directory to extract to I think
we're fine right now
so this download script is going to
download the path the all the weights
there now I want this to happen sort of
automatically while this is in a server
or while this is on a server so what I'm
going to do is probably just to so if
this script runs you can see it runs the
main but in the other script I might
just want to do this automatically so
let's go to the test script right here
or let's say we go to the Train script
this is probably the main script right
here the Train script so we have to
somehow call this other script here
probably in the main function all right
so let's import this other so import C
410 what was it called C 410 download ok
and here we're going to call that and
does this does this not download it if
it already exists we have to check that
so a lot of this is just going to be you
know beating the stuff into beating
stuff into into existence so if this zip
file already exists we're not going to
we're not going to do anything right
which leaves us open if like if the
unzipping fails then we're going to be
in a kind of dumb path but you know
we'll risk it
zip path would be that so that's if OS
path exists zip path then return okay so
we're good
in the download script what else do we
need the data set I probably already
have the data set from torture vision so
that's not going to be an issue okay so
here we're gonna call C for 10 download
dot main all right and that should do we
can't really call that yet let's
actually just run this download script
no no such file or directory probably
need to make that probably need to make
that directory right okay if OS make
there's models path exists okay true
yeah that should be something all right
and we're downloading so this is two
point four gigabytes which can you know
be put by itself let's put that over
there and while that's downloading let's
check out the test script actually let's
check out the test script so this simply
takes in this C 410 module and
instantiates
a trainer and as you can see it calls
tests on it so this should not be too
hard I'm going to guess this C 410
module is a lightning module as you can
see right here it is
we know how 10 sorry pi torch lightning
works if you don't know how Patrick
lighting works pretty easy you've
configured this module right here you
configure a bunch of stuff like the data
sets the training step and so on and
you're good to go
so I guess what we're going to do is
we're going to change this train script
and change it to our needs
okay so let's copy that let's go with
terrain ensemble dang so this is what
we're going to change all right so first
if the GPUs is a string then yada yada
yada if it's 2 then wow that's that's
that's kind of a weird engineering quirk
right here okay what I want to do is
make the GPU use transparent so we'll
only ever use one GPU so let's call that
CUDA and put that to true and then we'll
say done Oh aha come on there is like a
lot of stuff going on here let's so
and then torch is called torch I'd hate
that can I do this can I import it like
twice with different names probably it's
probably not very good but I'll do it
okay so if CUDA is not available we'll
just set the CUDA to false if th Kudarat
is available okay not if it's not
available then H Parramatta equals false
and then we'll set the GPUs to zero
comma I guess that's what it expects if
else none and that should do it for the
GPUs okay so second thing that we need
we're going to need we're calling fit
here and there is a this logs directory
where the check points are going to be
saved I'm fine with that I just want to
kind of remove the logs directory at the
beginning so I'll do that and whenever
we start this I'm going to remove the
logs directory this is a controversial
move but you know remove tree
recursively to rate the leader directory
tree yes logs good
okay our download is done so what do we
do next
we might want to do just try to test
test something and here in the test
thing we might want to set the GPUs I
don't have a GPU right here so none and
the data directory is going to be output
it so
nope nope nope okay it doesn't find the
it doesn't find the these state dicks
and so on now we're going to have to fix
this we're going to have to fix the fact
that it doesn't load okay okay and
that's probably going to be here in
these models so if I look in the dense
net for example which we can learn and
there's this pre-trained argument and
what's that going to be its oh that's
bad okay it like has hard code at the
fact as a hard-coded the fact that there
are there is this state dicts directory
okay yeah that's terrible terrible
terrible terrible so I guess this is
going to be in every single one of these
models and that's not good so what we're
going to do is probably always late
loaded without the pre-trained and then
kind of load it ourselves from the from
the correct directory so what's the
correct directory again we're going to
set the model dear we probably can just
take that from the download script like
that state dick
okay and then we want the architecture I
guess that's a thing we can actually put
the classifier here right here that's
something we can so it's going to be the
classifier if you look in this state Dix
directory I'm gonna guess you can deter
models see for ten state dicks
we haven't unpacked it where have we not
where have we unpacked it to help help
oh no have we unpacked it to here we
have not we have not so what is in here
ah it's a c4 ten models something and
then statics
okay so it's always going to be the
architecture plus PT so we can you know
we can deal with that
so it's going to be C for 10 models
state dicts that's fine and then it's
always going to be the architecture plus
a PT so let's look at one of these
models to see how this is loaded we've
saw we seen this here so we simply want
to load this state dict in and here it
constructs the thing this is let's do
proper string interpolation shall we oh
device where this device come from
we should check that out
[Music]
device is given device device device CPU
where is device given okay dense net
device CPU oh I guess device is always
CPU and then then we map it to wherever
I'm not entirely sure so here we say set
device I guess we can just get the
device from somewhere let's try it out
okay
so we're going to need this right here
so we're going to oh s path join models
path and something that's dot PT so and
here we're going to get the architecture
which is the classifier cool so that's
how we load something and then the
device maybe we can just go torch CUDA
dot get device is that possible
let's try
ah okay nope no get device device maybe
nope map location was given okay so we
have to figure out where this device
comes from honestly here
no module there is this get classifier
right here but just just as pre-trained
it's device always CPU I just can't
believe that I guess I'll believe it
will always load to the CPU okay cool we
can do that
I guess pi torch lightning will then put
it on the GPU for us cool so this is
about how far I got when I try to do
this by myself and now the problem start
missing keys ins they take a lot of
missing stuff we can't we can't possibly
load that yeah no not going to you so we
can't load stuff what does it do a lot
of load file name equals and then let's
paste this and let's put some kind of
breakpoint here so we can check it out
okay that exists no she feels like that
should exist yeah that exists what's the
what's the deal what's the matter here
so we got model which is I guess a resin
at 18 and we got this thing that we
might want to load so why doesn't it
work torch load load file name see that
works so that's the state dict
is that let's look at its keys we got a
you know a bunch of stuff okay so why
can't we load that moral load state dict
stay ticked and now unexpected keys in
state dick missing keys so this is
always prepended with model dot and here
it's not okay what do we do about that
I guess this is because we loaded
ourselves okay cool
so our model is not yes
so our model has the subpath model so we
need model model dot load state dict
right look at us we made it so this is
testing I guess this is this resonant 18
or what not so we can leave that to run
for itself so we figured out how to load
this stuff took us a while now let's go
ahead and we know how to load the models
we know how to load the weights so this
is our teacher model right our teacher
model is supposed to load up the weights
and then and then teach the student
models so here what is this training
thing do we download the thing we make
our GPUs to be really good okay and then
we instantiate this module right here as
you can see so now we're going to check
out this module by the way the testing
is done and as you can see there's an
accuracy of 93 0.33 which I'm pretty
happy with this is congruent with what
we saw right here
the ResNet 18 do okay and we can I guess
we can take a reson at 18 or a ResNet 50
they're both fairly small right here so
a lot of them are going to fit on our
GPUs once we use the GPUs so let's
change this module around right here to
actually do the to actually do the let's
say the the proper thing that we want it
to do is so here we have self model as
you can see and it's get classifier and
the question is does it load it pre
trained so what we want to do is this is
going to be our teacher model and this
in this gate classifier we want pre
trained to be false all
right here we don't want any sort of we
don't want to load the pre-trained
instead what we want to do is we
actually want to have the we want to
load it ourselves right so here preach
and false and now we're going from our
test script we're going to take over the
path they fit the code that we used to
load this okay all right so but a beam
but a boom OS we don't have OS that
coming along just fine yep yep yep so
now here we're going to have our self
teacher model to load that state dict
all right so this is it for
initialization now we also need our
student models of course so our student
models are going to be a bunch of models
[Music]
where what do we say so this is going to
be a torch or like a module list there's
this module list torch table Anand dot
module list right so I initialize that
with a list and the list is going to be
get me the classifier and we're just
going to go for the same kind of
classifiers right now to really boil it
down to have the same architecture for
the students and for the teachers for BA
in range in range and here we probably
need a flag so H params dot num students
okay so these are going to be our
student models so let's quickly create
this num students thing right here I'll
probably have to have an integer and
we'll go with five students for now okay
so we're creating five students all of
them are not pre trained so we're going
to are we going to train them from
scratch or do we want actually to take
over the weights we probably don't want
to take over the weight so let's just
train them from scratch in a
distillation mode I have no clue about
this stuff by now by the way okay I
guess this concludes this already
concludes what we what we wanted to do
so I guess this module list what can we
do with it does anyone know I don't know
by the way I'm sorry for the switching
between the dark and the bright
background I don't know how to fix that
so PI torch and an module list it would
be nice if we can give them some names
right so I guess that's just an iterable
right here so probably there is nothing
that we can do to give them proper names
or we'd have to hack around and I don't
want to do that so I guess we can just
check if that actually computes until
here so let's check it out let's try the
ensemble it doesn't data set not found
or corrupted okay so what we'll have to
do is we'll have to implement off to
change this data directory right here so
the data dear is going to be OS this
whatever my see for 10 directory is no
such file or directory logs
okay so logs doesn't exist so let's
actually make it still no such file or
directory logs why why doesn't it make
it no such file or directory logs ah
okay we need to ignore errors here and
we're good okay so it computes until the
point you probably you probably can't
see that right I guess now you can see
it let's check yeah now you can see it
all right so where are we we are at the
point right here in our module after
we've created the teacher and the
students so if we look at self
technically we should be able to see
right here a whole bunch of ResNet 18s
whole bunch so here you can see the
teacher model right and I'm going to
guess you can see layer four and here
you can see the student models so the
student models are going to be in it
whole list of models and now we're going
to train them so since they're
initialized differently
our hope is going to be that they're
sort of going to end up at different
places we're going to train them with
the same like we're going to be really
really stupid about this okay all right
so let's be really stupid about it so
what what we gonna have to change here
is our training step and our training
step is actually fine we'll simply
forward will get a loss from that and
then we are going to return that and
that's going to be back prompt so in our
optimizer wherever we initialize our
optimizer we should probably give it the
parameters that are not only the student
model parameter
ters right not the teacher model
parameters so it should only train the
student models okay and even even like
that we should probably always set the
teacher model in in eval mode but we'll
do that in the forward step right here
so in the forward step we get images and
labels and here it runs it just forward
through the model we want to change that
we actually want to have teacher
predictions which we're going to have
the teacher model we're going to forward
this through the teacher models now the
criterion I'm gonna guess is a
cross-entropy
so the predictions here are actually
going to be log it's right and this is
this is good except that what we want to
do is have a distribution of over labels
so after the teacher here runs through
and let's put a breakpoint right here
and actually look at it I find it's
always easy if you go and just run until
the point where your are at the code and
then you can just look at stuff so here
there's oh there's a validation sanity
check okay probably don't want that and
now we have the break right here and now
we can look at teacher predictions about
shape so that's a batch size times 10
and if we look at it I'm going to guess
there's some negative numbers in there
so that's not going to be that those are
going to be logins now we want them that
to be a soft max over the last dimension
and that's going to be of the same shape
but of course now we're going to have a
proper distribution so if we sum over
the last dimension you should see a
bunch of ones all right so the teacher
predictions are going to be soft max
over the last dimension and since we
since we don't want to backprop through
the teacher we
can do this in an environment of no grad
right here so we have that with not
being stupid and we also set the teacher
modeling to eval mode so I guess that
does it set train No
that should do it
I have no idea yeah let's let's run it
again we could have done that there okay
so so far so good so we have the teacher
predictions now what we need to do is
run them through the student and use
them as labels so we'll go for student
in student models
we'll go student forward or we simply
run the images through that and that
give us the log it's and then we use our
loss function on the log it's and not
the labels but the teacher predictions
right so we never actually use the
labels here as you can see and that's
going to be the student loss and now we
have a bunch of losses and we're going
to append that all right
nope don't like this and our loss is
simply going to be the sum of all the
student losses not even the average I
guess we could losses I guess we could
make it the average just so if we change
the number of students we'll we'll get
some kind of some sort of a better sense
of the the actual numbers what what what
okay I think over here we're good yeah
so the our teacher model is not in
training mode but our student models
hopefully or in training mode know is
this the eval pass I guess this is the
eval pass this is the validation sanity
check pass okay so this is going to be
our loss and our accuracy now right so
okay what's going to be our accuracy our
accuracy is going to be we have these
student losses all of them and what we
are going to do is we're simply going to
take the maximum prediction across the
students pretty easy pretty easy but we
need to collect the log it's so
come on
so we'll also have the log it's upend
the e student log it's okay so we have a
whole bunch of log it's right here and
we'll get some predictions out of that
now the question is do we want to simply
take the mode or do we actually want to
run a softmax over each and then take
the average prediction
um not duper super sure but we can try
to do it in different different ways so
right now we might just want to take the
maybe the average log it and then run a
soft max on top of that because I'm
gonna guess the log it's our output of a
linear layer so they might behave more
in a linear fashion than if we were to
average the actual probabilities that
come out right maybe let's let's do this
okay so we'll go we'll take these log
it's they're all and we need to somehow
concatenate those or stack them so how
we're going to stack them so there are
256 they're batch size by number of
classes so we'll just stack them at
dimension 0 I guess that's fine and then
we are going to mean also across
dimension 0 so those are going to be our
log it's our final log it's and then our
predictions are going to be the Arg max
of the log it's in the last dimension
yep that should be pretty
straightforward I guess that's it
easy as that yes the rest here should
just do by itself and I'm going to go
ahead and run give this another run and
see where we run into problems
can't really see how this could ever go
wrong
we'll just take everything over okay
we actually got a problem 1d target
tensor expected multi target not to
support it so the cross-entropy loss in
pi torch does not support that let's
let's give it a shot make this a little
bigger for you and let's go for the
cross P loss I can't type today so here
we have the cross entropy loss and the
cross entropy loss is useful in training
classification problem of the classes
yadda yadda yadda which we want okay
criterion expects a class index as the
target okay so what we need is like a
soft loss right we don't need this cross
entropy loss we actually want we want to
have soft targets so what do we do we
want to do I think the cross entropy
loss is a combination of the hear of the
log softmax and the NLL loss can we take
the NLL loss maybe so the NLL loss right
here is going to be the target that this
loss expects should be a class index no
okay that's not good so next let's go do
we have
we somehow need a soft cross and two
pillows
let's search for that hi torch soft
cross-entropy
soft classes I guess people who do that
kind of stuff so the problem with these
kind of losses is that what you do what
you have to do is kind of protect
yourself against against numerical
instabilities right so what we want to
do is find a function that does this for
us I guess if we do the loft the log
softmax that should take care of it for
us okay
this is tensorflow okay following thread
cross-entropy loss I guess people just
do really the log softmax and then do
that and we should be fine with this
okay thanks kay Frank yeah
maybe maybe this has advanced since then
so we can give like a last look at this
and this is a bit too big I'm sorry your
eyes are gonna have to suffer and we're
going to look at loss functions and
we're going to just look through them
multi-label soft margin loss mm
multi-label we don't really want
multi-label right we want this but not
with the targets
okay I guess we're just gonna have to
write this ourselves so ultimately what
is the cross entropy that cross entropy
is simply the probability of the true
label times the log probability of the
wrong order of the predicted label Yaffe
as you see right here
so we are going to simply multiply
target times the log probability of the
predicted label and then some some take
that mean across the batch I guess yeah
that should do we can implement this
let's do it
so this criterion right here is going to
be our loss function and that's only
used once so what we can do is going to
be a function so we're going to take
student log its and we're going to take
teacher probabilities okay so how is
that gonna work out
we're going to do the log softmax from
the student log it's so and then dot
that exists log softmax functional okay
we need functional and student log it's
of that dimension so now we have
properly normalized student log it so
that's going to be student log probs and
then what we want to do is simply
multiply the teacher probs times the
student log probs and the negative of
that is going to be our loss the
question is do we want to sum that I
guess across this dimension
or mean it I guess some some should do
all right this is it easy as that why
have we searched for so long so the
criterion we can simply replace that now
by our loss function cool so let's run
it again yadda yadda yadda okay sanity
check maybe we should have taken like a
smaller model it sometimes pays off to
you know start with a really small a
little small model just so you can you
can do these kind of things fast so here
we have dimension out of range today
okay which is where is that in forward
in line 78 let's go there line 78 okay
here the max is not going to be as much
fun let's like let's go there I think
this is some of these things change over
time in pi torch so this code might be
written when you know so what we have is
we have a max over the predictions and
the predictions o is already in our max
so I guess we can remove this all
whether or not that agrees with labels
dot data we don't need any of that dot
float and we also don't need that we so
the accuracy is simply going to be the
mean of this no I guess so we're here
can we just do predictions equals labels
yes and we want
the some of that actually we want the
float first and then we want the mean
yeah that seems reasonable so let's do
it like this get it undone float me
perfect how could this be any more easy
what this right here is all of it so
validation step accuracy corrects well
just look at it once we done it and what
I do is usually just run it until it
doesn't give me any mistakes anymore and
then I know I sort of have succeeded
okay we're pretty close I feel so it
says grad can implicitly created only
four scalar outputs which probably means
our loss function is not a scalar so
when we return the loss right here
here we have the sum of the losses
divided by the length of the losses
let's go here and check out what's up
with that
so what we'll do I see this loss
function here will output basically one
loss for each data point so what we need
to do I guess
is call mean on this or some when they
created the criterion in the original
one now we've thrown it away look at the
get diff right here so I guess this
reduces how does this reduce the cross
entropy loss when we don't do anything
the cross entropy loss reduces reduction
mean okay so let's reduce with the mean
so if we call loss then after that we
should call mean and then here I'm not
so sure anymore we should divide here
because the learning rate is kind of
tuned to the original lost size so I
guess we'll be content for now with
summing up these things and over here I
guess we've we've solved that right you
know losses yeah see our losses is going
to be an entire tensor and now we just
fixed that right now okay so let's try
it again in the meantime what can we do
we can so we already take care of our
GPU we take care of the logs one thing
to do when with respect to this download
stuff right here
is you know if you have a server or
something and you let a lot of things
around in parallel what you want to do
is make sure they don't all download the
same stuff at the same time that's
pretty bad so what you want to do is
ideally have some sort of lock such that
they coordinate and I usually use a file
lock for this so I'm gonna create that
right here from import the file lock and
then I simply create the lock let's go
buy a lock and here you have to input a
file so sometimes like date lock I don't
know you just pick some file and that's
the file that these these processes are
going to sync on and then once you do
this you simply wrap all of it in a with
lock so only one at a time can go in in
this function at direct direct all right
so that's that that should make us safe
and right here we're now training this
is excellent
we are training the students now we need
to do that on an actual GPU so I have
multiple tools to ship this to a GPU so
first of all I can try to ship this to
and try to ship this to a let's say two
to one GPU so the way you do that is
first of all I want some sort of
unbuffered version of Python and then I
have this do I even have this tool I do
have the tool okay so I'm going to call
one of our servers
and we don't know what's going on okay
so cannot import name seed everything
from PI torch lightning seed everything
is that some kind of new thing in PI
torch lightning I guess I have it
apparently so
here seed everything with zero why I
don't need that we are running without
any seed here we are being really cool
okay next mistake cannot okay still say
mistake of course since we don't yep
next mistake we'll just go through the
mistake learning rate late little
learning rate loggers so I guess we need
to update pi torch lightning on the
servers and I'll do that quickly
ok I've updated by George lightning
let's check out whether or not we can
actually run something yeah we can run
something so this again is now
downloading this on the server while
this is happening there is another thing
we can do namely I have sort of sort of
made a system to run stuff on servers
which I like a lot honestly so I guess
we can try this out how do I hidden with
I okay so I'm gonna first of all delete
this delete this yes I guess delete this
cool and the skit folder is a bit
annoying
let's restructure because otherwise
it'll always ship the git folder with
everything up here does it do that yeah
I don't like to have the code in that
top level so quickly make a sources
directory move everything in there so
move the c-4 10 models into the source
directory move all the Python files into
the source directory no clear the logs
and we're much better much better
ok much better so what we what we will
do is my system requires like a file and
I'm just gonna copy one from another
project quickly
okay so we're back and I copy that over
as you can see you basically give hyper
parameters and it blasts the piper
parameters through in a kind of a random
search fashion
it's not too sophisticated but we can
work with it so ten that's the file
right for ten train ensemble yes that's
the file cool
and here we're just going to put all of
our hyper parameters and that will
remove the logs file
I'm okay with that but I want this
okay cool so what do we want we want
basically we just want to try it like a
bunch of times and then see like average
across it right
that's all maybe we want the the
architecture to change so let's say the
classifier is a ResNet 18 or a ResNet 34
or a ResNet 50 just so we have a bunch
of stuff to do do okay and this
downloaded and is training on GPU
hopefully if this works then we can ship
this off and we'll make this other hyper
parameter that I like to use called rep
which is just basically a dummy
parameter and so I can just repeat the
experiment a bunch of times and let's
put that in here so this is really that
this has this has no effect except for
randomizing it a bit I guess we can try
to seed stuff so whenever it says seed
everything will just seed it with this
I'll call it seed no is it here this
seed everything yeah so H params dot rep
sorry seed cool with this this is doing
something nice you can see so this is
unbuffered Python output thanks yeah so
what other classifiers do we have we can
again we can try a bunch of them we can
try all of them why don't we try all of
them
like this then let's go into this rat
file I don't know why I called it rat I
just wanted like some three-letter thing
[Music]
so yep like this and then we can just
take all of that crap and delete it and
delete this and those are going to be
all our models so our classifier is
going to consist of all of this stuff
let's I know I know I know I suck it
then don't tell me actually tell me I
want them tips trying to learn something
new like each week in vim but it is hard
and tend to make myself actually do it
so let's go let's go with just one
repetition so far if we if we are not
sure we can still up the number of
repetitions we don't even have the rep
right now this is called seed alright so
we have different classifiers and what
we're going to need we also have this
num students right let's go with one
with five and with 20 so here we got one
epoch done and we get a validation loss
do we get a validation accuracy
validating validating I have no idea
we'll cancel this right now and we'll go
ahead and just blast this on to our
servers and hopefully that that's gonna
work right yet is everything fine
everything's fine go know what
what
cool
and let me get back to you once this is
finished all right we're back so I've
just written some code here to extract
the results of that run and something
you know it's pretty interesting what
came out so in these plots you'll see on
the x-axis you have the number of
students in the ensemble remember these
students are all trained from the same
teacher the teacher you can see in
orange that's just a single teacher for
reference you can see that if you have
one student model it sometimes
underperforms or and sometimes
outperforms the single teacher model but
then if you have more student models you
can see that there is a pretty monotonic
relationship so here it's the reason
this fit doesn't finish here is because
there not enough space on the GPU for
that many student models but you can see
that the relationship here is fairly
monotonic here it's a bit of a kink so
the first idea like this this is really
astounding because these students have
all been trained from that single
teacher and they have been trained for
as long as the teacher has been trained
so they don't have more compute and a
teacher they've been trained from
scratch not from some check point or
from the teacher weights it's still
simple distillation from the teacher No
Labels
and the students are all in parallel as
well so they don't see different data or
even different data augmentations it's
the exact same order of the exact same
data points going through all of the
students the exact same learning rate
schedule there's no noise and so on
so the first thought that came to my
mind like something fishy is going on
here right like this this is this seems
like to like come on there's no new
information here so I thought hey I the
teacher the teacher model I've just
grabbed them from this from this repo
from this pre-trained checkpoints and
these preacher and checkpoints they are
you know the checkpoints that have
performed best on the validation set so
this is sort of a sneaky way of how we
could train on the validation set
because we annotate each data point in
the training data set with this
checkpoint and the checkpoint has been
selected for performing especially well
on the validation data set it could
explain why we get a gain on the
validation data set so what I did is I
retrained all of the teacher models such
that I just retrain them for these 100
epochs and I just took the last
checkpoint the all everything's the same
the hyford parameters learning rate
schedule and so on this is not tuned for
any particular model and it's pretty
like it's pretty standard it's like it's
not like zero point one two five eight
nine it's like zero point zero one and
100 epochs or so fairly standard
parameters and I took just took the last
checkpoint to make it didn't even look
at its performance to make sure that I
didn't you know select something that
was especially good on the validation
data set and the results here you see
are actually already the results of that
run which the previous run it was almost
the same like I was astounded how well
it works and then I thought hey maybe
I'm kind of you know cheating here so I
redid it with the teachers that are not
specifically selected and this is
already the results so that's pretty
cool right so then I wondered what
happens if I now if I increase my
training amount so I just let this run
for more like what if I let the students
run for more than the teacher has run
again there's no new information here so
you can see that the now that okay the
green is now the teacher the blue is a
hundred epochs and the orange is 250
epochs and you can see with that even
one student will outperform the teacher
but many students will outperform even
more so if you give more compute there's
lots of lots of headroom here to improve
you'll see this year I think this last
one with the blue line is just a bit of
a weird a weird configuration I guess if
you were to read
that that would you know fall in line so
this is pretty pretty weird right so I
have a bunch of questions so first of
all I've searched a literature a bit
more and I came up with a number of
papers that do things like this now
usually when you do distillation you
people stress the importance of like how
to introduce noise like in the noisy
student paper or that you really need
these data augmentations or you know sim
clearly to uses the self distillation in
order to do in in order to label more
data so they say it's important that we
bring more unlabeled data into the
process and so on so all of this
it really doesn't match right here and
especially this focus on we need noise
during the distillation process to build
these ensembles this is also you know if
you know mean teacher things like this I
also found a paper called born-again
neural networks that does something
quite similar but not very simp not like
the same where they distill a teacher to
the student with the same architecture
and then they distill the student again
into another student and then that into
another student and so on and then at
the end they say oh we can also build an
ensemble but sometimes their ensembles
outperform their you know chain of
distillation sometimes they don't they
don't really focus on that part a lot
and it's way more complicated like you
distill one student after another and I
also think they they have some
introduction of variability in the
students like like noise or different
augmentations and so on so this here it
seems you know really really really
simple now I want to know this ensemble
effect it seems pretty pretty weird
right so what gives so the first thing
we could do is we could say what what
does how does this compare to an
ensemble of teacher models like if we
actually were to build an ensemble like
train five teacher models on you know
five you know five different teacher
models it's still the same data but
reasonably they might be able to learn
something more from the data if we have
five teacher models they might learn
different things from the data and
therefore if we combine them they might
kind of overlap their knowledge and in
sort of catch where if one doesn't
generalize in one data point the other
four can overrule it whereas with this
student with these self ensembles
there's not really a way where we can
learn more from data because we can only
learn from the teacher and the teacher
is fixed and has seen that much data
right so how this is compare so wrote
some rewrote some code is it's just
plumbing and I release the code it's
linked but it's just plumbing don't
worry don't worry there is no great
thoughts in there it's just plumbing
such that my students don't are not all
in parallel so the ensemble's are not
trained in parallel anymore I train each
model individually which means that at
maximum I have to have two models on the
same GPU one teacher and one student so
I make sure that the teachers they are
trained from scratch and the students
they're always trained from the same
teacher right so the student ensembles
will be exactly the same as we have them
here that means one teacher is
responsible for all the students but
yeah so okay I'll just show you the
results right here so if we look at
those results you can see that and I've
done it for a bunch of models right here
the blue line is the ensemble of
teachers and here on the x-axis you see
the number of models and now since I'm
not training everything on the same GPU
but I recombine later that that
basically means that I have doubt the
ability to Train up to ten models or
actually however many I want and the
only real trick in the code is that when
I evaluate one of these ensembles what I
do is I load a mini batch and then I
basically load the first checkpoint
run the forward pass
load the second checkpoint run the
forward pass load the third check on run
a four loop as I do this for all the
checkpoints until I go to the next mini
batch but that's just for evaluating
right it just seemed easiest with the
code that I had so you can see right
here that the there is a significant
like this is almost overlapping right
here for most models there sometimes the
student wins sometimes the teacher wins
so the teacher ensemble wins now
remember the teachers are trained on you
know 10 times as much data right here
but again it's always the same data but
still they have the opportunity to learn
10 times as much information from the
data whereas the students they're all
distilled from that same teacher without
any noise any augment 8 any
augmentations except for the
augmentations that you use during
training anyway and I've done this for a
hundred epochs and I've done this for
250 is this already 250 I think that was
a hundred I just put that there
nope okay yeah that was a hundred epochs
but you see the 250 epoch plots they
look very much the same okay they're
just a bit better if you train for 250
epochs now interestingly okay here's the
interesting part about the 250 epochs
the student is still distilled from a
teacher model that has been trained for
a hundred epochs so I mean all of this
all of this makes no sense to me
right the student is still distilled
from the hundred epoch teacher model yet
if you train the student for 250 epochs
in self distillation and then build an
ensemble of these students from that
same teacher model and you compare that
to an ensemble of teachers that have all
been trained for longer for 250 epochs
which you know shoot out it the 250
epochs generally outperforms the hundred
epochs models still they are the same
this
this is pretty crazy results I I think
and sort of my conclusion from this is
that the ensemble effect right here is
not a function of learning of extracting
more information from the data the
ensemble effect might actually be have
something to do with the function
landscape itself and kind of exploring
different minima of the of the same
function not of the same function but
exploring different functions to
describe the same phenomena and I've
also found a paper that explains the
lost landscape of deep ensembles and I
will make a video on that maybe it's out
already maybe it will be out after you
see this one I I haven't decided yet
which which order I'm going to release
things but this here I it's it's pretty
interesting and we need like a name so
self self ensembles are already a thing
but they are always with noise and stuff
like this so let's call them something
like plain self ensembles but that that
sounds like a good name playing cell
phone samples the act of self
distillation a single model into
multiple models without any noise any
augmentations anything just you run as
if you were to train the model itself
and then you build an ensemble of these
models by simply averaging the log it's
playing cell phones almost all right so
the plan from here is to check on like
at least one other data set you know
these these models I appreciate that I
could get them pre-trained but they're
just the imagenet models and then kind
of let run on c 410 so there's no kind
of guarantee that these have been you
know tuned or anything that the learning
rates are whatnot so i wanna take like
an image net model you still make sure
that i don't use any like hidden
information where i could cheat on the
validation set but try this on at least
one thing and see if
that works as well if we can sort of
push imagenet performance simply by
doing this trick so that's the plan for
now and I have some other ideas but I
just wanted to let you know and this is
sort of how research works I guess you
have a dumb idea and it turns out to
work and then you go on and still
probably probably there is not maybe too
much interesting things here maybe it
doesn't work on imagenet because these
models are just under trained and this
somehow made them better somehow or
regularize them somehow that usually
doesn't work there's so much that can go
wrong still so but yeah that was it and
I invite you to like check out other
papers in this space if you want it's a
pretty interesting space and with that I
don't have much more to say yeah I hope
you enjoyed this let me know what you
think of like research implementation or
research process videos like this I'm
not sure what people expect like I can't
make this into a five minute video of
like oh I discovered something because
then you know there's no clue of what's
what's happening but maybe like an hour
so is also too long I'm not sure yeah
let me know what you think and I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]